le midi pour les coureurs c'est le sar
le pays de la spa par une chaude journée
ils arrivent à transpirer 3 ou 4 litres
alors ils boivent ils boivent n'importe
quoi ce qui leur tombe sous la main de
la pierre du vin rouge du champagne et
chocolats glace
je vous précise que le record d'un
changement de roue dans le tour de
france et de 8 secondes il ne sera pas
battu ne l'euro danois qui se battaient
pour garder sa troisième place
rasmussen a chuté deux fois ait changé
trois fois de vélo
il ya des jours comme ça où tout va de
travers qui est dans le ravin une
cinquantaine de mètres en contre par à
l'origine de la confusion le gendarme il
fait signe aux coureurs de tourner à
gauche
en même temps il indique aux voitures et
aux motos suiveuses de continuer tout
droit niveau watier milliards non
compris à qui s'adresser ses gestes
le plus dur en effet face à des
adversaires décidés à prendre tous les
risques pour détrôner le roi
joseba beloki a fait trembler amstrong
dans les alpes mais dans une descente à
couteaux tirés
l'espagnol chute et abandonne
l'américain s'offre une belle frayeur
mais reprend sa marche triomphale sans
se retourner